This lecture is about the evaluation of
text retrieval systems.
In the previous lectures we have talked
about a number of text retrieval
methods, different kinds of ranking
functions.
But how do we know which one works the
best?
In order to answer this question, we
have to compare them and that means we
have to evaluate these retrieval
methods.
So this is the main topic of this
lecture.
First, let's think about the why do we
have to do evaluation?
I already give one reason and that is
we have to use evaluation to figure out
which retrieval method works better.
Now this is very important for
advancing our knowledge, otherwise we
wouldn't know whether a new idea works
better than old idea.
In the beginning of this course, we
talked about the problem of text
retrieval.
We compared it with database retrieval.
There we mentioned that text retrieval
is empirically defined problem.
So evaluation must rely on users.
Which system works better would have to
be judged by our users
So this becomes a very challenging
problem.
Because.
How can we get users involved in the
evaluation?
How can we do a fair comparison of
different methods?
So just go back to the reasons for
evaluation.
I listed two reasons here.
The second reason is basically what I
just said, but there is also another
reason which is to assess the actual
utility of text retrieval system.
Now imagine you're building your own
search engine applications.
It would be interested in knowing how well
your search engine works for your
users.
So in this case, matches must reflect
the utility to the actual users
in a real application. And typically
this has to be done by using user
studies and using the real search
engine.
In the second case, or for the second
reason.
The measures actually only to be
correlated with the utility to actual
users.
Thus they don't have to accurately
reflect the exact utility to users.
So the measure only needs to be good
enough to tell which method works
better.
And this is usually done through a test
collection, and this is the main idea
that we'll be talking about in this
course.
This has been very important for
comparing different algorithms and for
improving search engine system in
general.
So next we talk about what to measure
right?
There are many aspects of a search
engine that we can measure we can
evaluate.
And here I listed the three major
aspects.
One is effectiveness or accuracy.
How accurate the other search results.
In this case, we're measuring systems
capability of ranking relevant
documents on top of non random ones.
The second is efficiency.
How quickly can a user get some
results?
How much computing resources are needed
to answer query?
So in this case we need to measure the
space and time overhead of the system.
The third aspect is usability.
Basically, the question is how useful
is a system for real user tasks.
Here, obviously interfaces and many
other things are also important, and we
typically would have to do user
studies.
Now in this course we are going to talk mostly
about effectiveness and accuracy
measures because the efficiency and
usability dimensions are not really
unique to search engines and so.
They are needed for evaluating any
other software systems, and there is
also good coverage of such materials in
other courses.
But how to evaluate a search engines
quality or accuracy is something unique
to text retrieval, and we're going to
talk a lot about this.
The main idea that people have proposed
for using a test set to evaluate text
retrieval algorithm is called the Cranfield
evaluation methodology.
This one actually was developed a long
time ago, developed in 1960s.
It's a methodology for laboratory test.
Of system components, it's actually
methodology that has been very useful
not just for search engine evaluation,
but also for evaluating virtually all
kinds of empirical tasks.
And for example, in natural language
processing or in other fields where the
problem is empirically defined, we
typically would need to use such a
methodology.
And today with the Big Data Challenge
with use of machine learning everywhere,
this methodology has been very
popular, but it was first developed for
search engine application in 1960s.
So the basic idea of this approach is
to build a reusable test collections
and define measures.
One such a test collection is build.
It can be used again and again to test
the different algorithms, and we're
going to define measures that would
allow you to quantify the performance
of a system or an algorithm.
So how exactly would this work?
We're going to have a sample collection
of documents and this is just to
simulate the real document collection
in search application.
We can also have a sample set of
queries or topics.
This is to simulate users queries.
Then we'll have to have relevance
judgments.
These are judgments of which documents
should be returned for which queries.
Ideally they have to be made by users
who formulated the queries, 'cause
those are the people that know exactly what
documents would be useful, and then
finally we have to have measures to
quantify how well systems result
matches the ideal ranked list that
would be constructed based on users
relevance judgments.
So this methodology is very useful for
starting retrieval algorithms because
the tested connection can be reused
many times and it would also provide a
fair comparison for all the methods.
We have the same criteria, same data
set to be used to compare different
algorithms.
This allows us to compare a new
algorithm with an older algorithm that
was developed many years ago by
using the same standard.
So this is an illustration of how this
works.
So as I said, we need the queries that
are shown here. We have
Q1Q2, etc.
We also need the documents that's
called a document collection and on the
right side you see we need relevance
judgments.
These are basically.
The binary judgments of documents with
respect to a query.
So, for example d1 is judged as
being relevant to Q1, D2 is judged as
being relevant as well.
And d3 is judged as non
relevant.
The two, Q1, etc.
These would be created by users.
But once we have these and then we
basically have a text collection and
then if you have two systems you want
to compare them then you can just run
each system on these queries and
documents and each system would then
return results.
Let's say if the query is Q1 and then
we would have results.
Here I show R sub A as results from
system A.
So this is remember we talked about.
Task of computing approximation of the
relevant document set R sub A  is
system A's approximation here.
And R sub B is system B's
approximation of relevant documents.
Now let's take a look at these results.
So which is better now?
Imagine for a user, which one would you
like?
Now let's take a look at the both
results.
And there are some differences, and
there are some documents that are
returned by both systems.
But if you look at the results, you
would feel that well, maybe A is better
in the sense that we don't have many
non relevant documents and among the
three documents returned,
two of them are relevant, so that's
good, it's precise.
On the other hand, one can also say,
maybe B is better because we've got
more relevant documents.
We've got 3 instead of two.
So which one is better and how do we
quantify this?
Obviously this question highly depends
on the users task and it depends on
users as well.
You might be able to imagine for some
users may be system A is better.
If the user is not interested in
getting all the relevant document.
But in this case, the user
doesn't have to read many and the
user would see most of the relevant
documents.
On the one hand,  one can also
imagine the user might need to have as
many relevant documents as possible.
For example, if you are doing a
literature survey, you might be in the
segment category and you might find that
system B is better.
So in that case we will have to also
define measures to quantify them.
And we might need to define multiple
measures.
Because users have different
perspectives of looking at the results.